[MUSIC PLAYING]
MEGAN YAHYA: Welcome to the
Google Cloud Security Showcase,
a special live
series where we we'll
focus on security use
cases that customers
can solve with Google Cloud.
My name is Megan Yahya,
and I'm Product Manager
at Google Cloud.
Today, we'll be walking through
one of the top questions we
get from customers.
How can I detect
network-based threats
in my Google Cloud environment?
Cloud IDS is Google Cloud's
network-based threat-detection
technology that detects
malware, spyware,
command-and-control attacks, and
many other classes of exploits.
It provides fully-managed
network threat detection
with high levels of security
efficacy and low noise.
It's quick and easy to
deploy, fully managed, scaled,
and operated by Google
with high performance
and availability built in.
We have partnered with our
friends at Palo Alto Networks
to embed their industry-leading
threat-detection technologies
to make sure we have
industry-leading detection
both in breadth of
coverage and efficacy,
backed by their expert
production-proven technologies
and world-class
threat-intelligence teams.
Here is a broad overview
of how Cloud IDS works.
Cloud IDS is a fully
managed cloud-native product
that receives the mirrored
traffic from customers' network
and runs threat detection
technology from Palo Alto
Networks under the hood.
Cloud IDS may be applied
via packet mirroring
to any and all traffic
to or from a workload.
Whether it's a compute engine
in GCE or a container in GKE,
Cloud IDS moves threat detection
closer to the workload.
Not just VPC to
internet or VPC to VPC,
but also intra-VPC
traffic are inspected
for full north-south
and east-west visibility
and detection.
This dramatically
simplifies the fulfillment
of the IDS requirement common
to several compliance marks.
It also fills in the east-west
blindspots suffered by most
SOCs in cloud environments.
Cloud IDS also
integrates with SOAR,
which is the Security
Orchestration and Automated
Response solutions, such as Palo
Alto Networks XSOAR product.
This enables customers to set
up automated threat responses
based on Cloud IDS's alerts.
We have built integrations
with third-party SIEM solutions
which provide security
information and event
management to our customers.
Leveraging these
partner solutions
in conjunction with
cloud IDS gives customers
additional visibility into
network threats and security
analytics on Cloud IDS alerts.
We are also building
integrations
with Chronicle
security analytics
platform and SCC, the security
management platform on GCP.
Now, let me show
you how you can use
Cloud IDS to detect
network-based threats
in your Google
Cloud environment.
Here is how Cloud IDS looks
like inside GCP environment.
It is located under
Network Security section
next to Cloud Armor and
SSL policies products.
Once you click on Cloud
IDS, it browse you
to the Dashboard
page, where you can
see a summary of top threats
and IP addresses that have been
detected within your alerts.
You can customize the
dashboard using the time
filters at the top
by selecting the time
period you're interested in.
In order to get
started, you first
need to create
Cloud IDS endpoints.
An endpoint is a
cluster of VMs that
are running Palo Alto
Networks threat-detection
technology under the hood.
So first, I enter
the endpoint name.
Then enter the network
that you want to inspect.
If you have a shared VPC, this
would be the host product.
Cloud IDS creates a
peered VPC network
attached to the network
you specify here.
The next step allows you to
specify minimum threat severity
alerts you would like to see,
such as Low and above, where
Low is for minor threats with
little impact on organization's
infrastructure, and
Critical is a serious alert.
Once you create this
endpoint, you're
going to see it
under Endpoints tab.
Now you have an
IDS endpoint that
is ready to receive and inspect
traffic and generate threats,
but it is not
receiving any traffic
yet until you attach a packet
mirroring policy to it that
will mirror the traffic
from the associated VPC.
Click Attach to set up your
packet-mirroring policy.
Now, traffic from
the specified source
is mirrored to the IDS
endpoint for inspection.
So you give the policy a name.
And you picked the
mirrored sources.
And you press Submit.
The policy is going to show
up next to your endpoint,
such as this policy that
I had created before.
And that's it.
Now, you have your
endpoint, and you have
the packet-mirroring policy.
So the traffic is
flowing to the endpoint,
and the detection is happening.
So you can go to the Threats
tab to see the reported threats.
The Time filter
on top allows you
to view threats for a
specific time period.
You can also use the
Filter menu to filter
by other threat properties,
such as severity or source IP
addresses.
You can now click
on a specific threat
to get more details
about that threat.
Once you click on
View threat details,
it's going to take you
to Threat Details page.
Threat Details page also
shows the application
based on Application
Identification technology,
App ID.
It also shows you information
about the CV, severity,
threat type, and more
description about the alert.
If you go back, you can see
that, alternatively, you
can click on View threat logs.
That will take you to a new
tab with threat information
in Cloud Logging.
Cloud Logging also enables
downstream integrations
with your SIEM tools
such as Splunk or SOAR
tools such as Palo Alto XSOAR.
You can also create
custom workflows
to take remediation action based
on alerts, such as creating
a Cloud Function that
triggers on an alert
and generates a firewall
rule to block the IP address.
Thank you for tuning in.
Please visit
cloud.google.com/security
for more content from
Google Cloud experts.
[MUSIC PLAYING]